la parole est donc donnée maintenant à
notre collègue Thierry kzic pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
voilà réunis pour voter le premier texte
entièrement consacré aux douanes depuis
1965 nul doute que ce dernier
nécessitait un toilettage
légistique ce texte est donc essentiel
et son historique n'est pas
neutre le vote de cette loi est
importante car il nous renvoie notre
mission de
parlementaire qui sur ce texte a pour
vocation essentielle
l'obligation de sécuriser juridiquement
la capacité d'action des douanes sur
l'ensemble du territoire
national tout en rendant le droit de
visite douanière pleinement conforme à
la
Constitution je rappelle que le code des
douanes étant très ancien jusqu'à
présent il n'incorporait pas les
garanties en matière de protection des
droits des personnes et des libertés
individuelles qui se sont développé ces
30 dernières
années par ailleurs au regard des actes
de procédure qui découle du
texte je pense que nous devrions
reprendre la très bonne
formulation de notre collègue Daniel
breuyet qui proposait la création d'un
code de procédure
douanière je tiens à dire je tiens à
dire que la commission des lois en
premier lieu mais également la
commission des finances se sont donné
comme mission de sécuriser les
procédures de visite de fouille et de
perquisition mise en
place ce projet mis à part son article 7
relatif la réserve opérationnelle et sur
laquelle je souhaite m'attarder ne pose
que peu de difficultés
techniques en revanche il subsiste des
doutes malgré l'examen du texte et vos
précisions monsieur le
ministre le texte organise également la
remise d'une personne à un officier de
police ou de douane judiciaire sur
instruction du contrôle du procureur de
la République en cas d'infraction
flagrante de droit commun
en outre ce projet de loi encadre la
sonorisation et la captation d'image
sous l'autorité d'un magistrat ce qui ne
passe pas l'essentiel des pouvoirs dans
les mains de l'autorité administrative
le contrôle du juge indépendant est de
nature à garantir les garanties de
liberté fondamentale auquel cette
assemblée est attachée le dispositif
proposé va donc dans le bon sens et ce
en octroyant des garanties sans modifier
la finalité du droit de visite douanière
et les opérations matérielles de
contrôle le code des douanes est révisé
afin de ne plus autoriser les agents des
douanes de procéder en toute
circonstance à des opérations de visite
pour la recherche de toute infaction
douanière sur l'ensemble du territoire
douanier à l'encontre de toute personne
se trouvant sur la voie
publique concernant l'article 7 durant
les débats monsieur le ministre vous
nous avez rétorqué que la réduction du
schéma d'emploi des douane dans la
dernière loi de finance est liée au
transfert à la DG FIP d'une activité de
recouvrement les gains de productivité
réalisés bénéficient pour moitié au
douanes cela ne m'a pas
convaincu j'entends qu'il s'agira de
recruter 300 douaniers réservistes afin
de répondre à des besoins
ponctuel cependant monsieur le
rapporteur a rappelé que cette réserve
va permettre de se doter de compéten RAR
ce qui atteste vous me permettrez du
flou des perspectives généré par une
telle
création de plus si l'on peut comprendre
la logique des besoins ponctuels lors de
pic d'activités récurrent je pense au
contrôle aux frontières en période
saisonnière dans certaines zones du
territoire ou exceptionnelles comme les
Jeux Olympiques l'article ne précise pas
assez les missions de ces réservistes et
vos explications n'ont pas été de nature
à dissiper ce
doute de fait je m'interroge encore
grandement sur la pertinence de
restauration d'un tel dispositif qui ne
visera probablement à terme qu'à
justifier une diminution des effectifs
ou à tout le moins un gel des effectifs
de la douane en dépite de cet article 7
pour lequel j'ai met encore un avis
réservé le texte semble globalement
équilibré le travail des rapporteurs a
par ailleurs permis de renforcer les
qualités légistique du texte et de
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mécanismes de garantie formel
par conséquent le groupe ser votera ce
texte mais ce vote monsieur le ministre
n'est pas un blan jeens faire une
remarque plus politique et plus Glob sur
la manière dont notre Parlement
travaille ces derniers
mois monsieur le ministre alors que vous
n'avez pas de majorité structurelle pour
faire voter vos Tex nous assistons
depuis quelques mois stratagè don nous
ne sommes pas
DUP votre stratégie qui une phrase
proposer des textes essentiellement
techniques systématiquement assortis de
moyens financiers nouveaux afin de
neutraliser toute critique politique sur
la finalité du texte et placer vos
oppositions et elles sont nombreuses
dans une présomption
d'irresponsabilité si elle ne vote pas
votre
texte lors de l'examen de la l'opnit
vous avez certes mis 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires sur 5 ans pour
les policiers et les gendarmes mais dans
le même temps cela vous a permis de pass
des dispositifs encore plus sécuritaires
et l'usage de texte technique et
complexe vous ont permis de ne pas
mobiliser une opinion qui peine à trier
le bon grain de
livret ces opérations de neutralisation
des oppositions par la force de
l'argument budgétaire se double souvent
d'un argument d'autorité qui voudrait
que nécessiter fait loi c'est ainsi que
pour la loi relative aux jeux olympiqu
et paralympique de 2024 vous n'avez pas
hésité à introduire des mesures aussi
contestables que celles figurant
l'article 7 visant à autoriser la la
vidéosurveillance assistée par
intelligence artificielle le procédé est
donc connu mais ces textes d'apparence
technique ne doivent pas masquer la
volonté politique qui les anime et que
nous dcelons en
filigrane revenir aux douanes nous
serons très attentifs au prochain au
prochain
PLF afin que vous joignez les actes aux
paroles nous espérons donc que vous vous
donnerez les moyens de vos ambitions et
que de notre douane disposera au-delà de
vos engagements de moyens concrets pour
s'acquitter de leur mission cruciale une
fois de plus vous pourrez compter sur le
Sénat pour y veiller
merci la
parole